organizers of the tokyo olympics have
announced a total ban
on spectators in the stadiums it follows
the declaration of a new state of
emergency in tokyo because of increasing
numbers of coronavirus cases
foreign fans had already been barred now
japanese spectators are being told to
stay at home
the games are due to begin in just over
two weeks and will be the first ever
olympics held behind closed doors
the olympic torch continued its long
journey towards tokyo to open the games
later this month while there were plenty
of fans cheering on the torchbearers as
they pass through the saitama prefecture
rising covet cases in the capital means
there won't be any fans to greet them
in tokyo government officials have
announced a state of emergency in tokyo
set to begin next week in a bid to curb
the spread of the virus
while the crux of the measure is cutting
the sale of alcohol at bars and
restaurants to help limit social
activities it will also directly affect
the olympics
although the number of severely ill
patients and the occupancy rates of
hospital beds have remained at a low
level
the impact of the variant strains must
be taken into account
we must strengthen the counter measures
to prevent the infections
from spreading to the rest of the
country again
while olympic organizers had already
capped spectators to 50 percent of venue
capacity and barred international fans
from attending
the new ruling now prevents any
spectators from attending the games
though public sentiment in japan has
widely turned against hosting the
tournament
olympic organizers have dug in their
heels and are committed to seeing the
games through
we continue to
be committed to our principle of
organizing
safe olympic and paralympic games
together
with you and we
have shown you know this responsibility
since the day of the postponement
the games are estimated to have cost
more than 20 billion dollars cancelling
them which should cut off broadcasting
revenue
would make recouping any of that next to
impossible for tokyo
and the international olympic committee
for better or for worse
just like the olympic torch the games
look set to march on
let's get more from mark meadows from dw
sport welcome
mark um comet is responsible for all
sorts of unprecedented uh
things over this last couple of years um
now we have a spectator-free
olympics what sort of games then are we
in for
a very very strange one uh as you say
we've got used to this idea of not
having fans in stadiums over the last 18
months especially with football
but when it comes to the biggest
sporting event of all that only comes
around every four years
it's a big big blow it's a big blow for
the japanese athletes
because they were really counting on
having japanese fans in the stands
pushing them along japanese fans tend to
be very passionate very excited
we already knew that spectators from
abroad weren't going to be there but
still
it's going to change the whole sort of
ethos of the games really i mean you
think about when you
when you watch it even on television the
fans are part of the games
maybe when you're watching archery or
rowing you don't see the fans quite so
much but in the really big sports like
athletics
and swimming especially the noise when
it comes to swimming
the fans are a big big part of it so
it's going to feel very very strange
so well you you you mentioned the
football there so we're we're in the
middle of the european football
championships we've seen large crowds
we've seen large crowds at wembley
while london is in the middle of an
increasing number of coronavirus
infections so what is the difference
between the two events the two cities
i guess the japanese are being extra
cautious
uh it is true that in britain the
vaccine rate is higher than in
in japan so japan fears that if the
delta variant really uh
variant really grips there then they
could be in in serious trouble
and they decided they have no other
option even though as you say the cases
are
relatively low in compared to what we're
seeing in
in europe um i think also there's
political dynamics in there there's an
election coming up in
in japan in october uh but other people
will say people in europe are being too
rash i mean 60 000
fans at these england games at wembley
when cases are rocketing maybe in a
month two months time people will
realize that actually
japan took a very sensible course of
action right and the the international
olympic committee
is determined to press ahead with this
they have to
uh it's all about money basically i mean
it's cost billions and billions to host
the games
the postponement cost extra now they're
not getting ticket income
the only income they're getting is from
sponsors and from television
and if we're honest the sponsors care
about the tv viewers
not the spectators in the stands that's
how they make their money
and so that is basically what the ioc is
relying on
if they scrap these games the rrc would
be in
big big bother especially with the next
olympics the winter olympics being in
beijing
and various governments talking about
diplomatic boycotts
the best case scenario is an olympics
without fans
where at least you have the sport and
you have the tv viewers okay
thank you for that mark meadows dw sport